uh
no no
i'm not i'm not hurt by that comment
i've never seen no [ __ ] like this before
in my life you don't have you've never
had a match ever not on this i got like
one match on tinder and that that was
like a while back and that did not work
out
uh yeah no i am the world's most
undateable boy or man or whatever gender
you assumed assume me to be
that's the worst thing i've ever heard
yeah
yeah keep your head up
and i have to
otherwise my neck's gonna break
right
so since everything is like changed over
time right you're noticing that now most
people are meeting through online dating
right and that's not necessarily a bad
thing i think online dating is positive
in a lot of ways you get to meet people
you would never meet and interact with
possibly you have an opportunity to you
know try to talk to as many people as
possible
but
i'm going to speak specifically to the
men because i think the male and the
female experience online dating is
completely different
guys
if you aren't the most physically
attractive especially like towards your
face okay
don't
push yourself on online dating or make
it your avenue to meet people because it
is the worst way for you it's going to
be deceptive one your height doesn't
translate super well in online dating
okay
pretty much it's like a face thing right
and then from there you're hiding all
that stuff factors in but like if you
don't got it you don't got it
right so rather than put your [ __ ]
self-esteem through that beating if they
can't handle it go find ways where it's
more optimal to you the guy in question
was relatively tall probably like five
eight five nine so still you know above
average height okay
decent build
if he was in a social environment with
social activities
right where you're naturally talking to
the opposite sex and you're meeting
people on a regular basis he would meet
women he would have more chances
to showcase something else than just
face and this because what you see on
tinder is really quick
so yeah so my point is it's like
understand what your skill sets are what
you have okay because tinder nobody
knows your personality you're not gonna
get to know you're not gonna be like oh
my god this guy looks like he's funny
that's not happening they're looking at
your face
and they're swiping
so
if you're not having success there it's
because your skill sets don't translate
to that platform so i tell this to a lot
of dudes like get off of that
go learn a hobby that you actually
interact with the opposite sex there's
plenty of them out there right go do
stuff that gives you a chance to
actually interact with them but if
you're not going to do that
you're going to limit your opportunities
to meet them i mean i know dudes who
[ __ ] work at a tech tech
tech company or they work at [ __ ]
future shop or best buy and it's like
just dudes working there and they don't
have any hobbies they don't have
anything and they're all online
and now you don't have no way to meet
people your job doesn't even give you an
opportunity and most people we at work
so my advice to folks is like understand
what you got going for you and then work
accordingly not everyone's gonna have
the best hand dealt to them online
dating wasn't for me i had a bit of
success there but very limited
okay
i had to learn to do other [ __ ] so
i understand it's a struggle i know it's
hard i know like being invisible i know
what it's like
when you've been swiping all day right
you've been swiping
days have passed by your homies getting
matches they're going on dates they talk
about how they get laid you're not
getting nothing and sometimes when you
do get matched and it's hot it's a
[ __ ] bot some girl trying to sell you
on her cam like it's crazy that she'll
piss a man off well you hot mess like i
if i mess with a hot girl now i don't
even believe she's real i agree yeah i'm
like
why are you talking to me box sometimes
it's a real person and they like what
the [ __ ] your problem so
just understand that
you know what i'm saying mm-hmm because
i'm not rude it's just that
hot matches with bot
it rhymes with hot map
it rhymes with bot the only messages i
usually get on uh dating apps are from
the date naps itself a while ago i made
a joke video talking about how i am
literally
the the cover man for being ghosted or
ignored and how to handle it i've tried
a wide assortment of like pictures from
me playing chess with like some rap
legends to like really good outfits that
my friend designs themself and she's a
girl and she was like oh these these
would be cool outfits we did photo
shoots and everything and i talked about
my super power
comedic timing
and it was it wasn't he does have that
was that was funny that was funny that
was great but in a normal setting it
would be fun on tinder [ __ ] i had even
picked up the bumble premium lifetime
i'm a member forever i got the super
swipes that i just stopped using because
every time i sweep somebody just nothing
really happened and then i turned on
spotlight
almost every single day and i still i
still don't get any uh
matches i have friends that are girls
and they always say john you'll be a
great boyfriend or i can't believe you
don't have a girlfriend yet and i'm like
well you could change that and they'd be
like nah i'd probably ruin our
friendship the fact that you're even
looking at girls that you call supposed
friends and talk about you could change
that already your approach to them is
like you've thrown yourself into the
dungeon you are in that friend zone okay
you put yourself there to get out of
that [ __ ] is impossible for most people
so you also have to understand you even
being disappointed by the fact that
somebody would say you'd make good
boyfriend materials like brother you've
put yourself in a situation with a girl
that you don't want to be your friend
you want her to be your girlfriend so
you have to also acknowledge like the
mistakes that you're making
that are contributing to your situation
i never had no girl taught me like you
make a good boyfriend like damn but you
could be my girlfriend that's lame bro
that's lame so you have to acknowledge
like
you don't want these friends you want
them for girlfriends and you need to
stop doing that [ __ ]
so maybe we shouldn't say things like
you would make a great boyfriend to me
because it kind of like messes my head
up a little bit they're not messing up
your head you're messing up your head
a lot of guys are out here lying talking
about yeah i got a bunch of girlfriends
no you don't you have girls you're
hoping to date
and you're being friendly with them you
have a bunch of girls that you're around
and you're waiting for them to be
vulnerable and then you'd be like trying
your [ __ ]
that let's be honest let's be honest you
be friends around them and then when
they're vulnerable you're like
maybe i could be the next one and you're
just
deceived every time that's what it is
and i get it because
me i used to say this all the time like
i couldn't do the whole friendship with
leagues like like real friendships i
could be cordray i could be cool
amicable see them what's up but i'm
talking about like we just hanging out
amicably all the time and like there's
no i couldn't do that because generally
i would be attracted to them so i'm like
i'm not gonna do that right
now in my older years it's a lot easier
because i don't even want it i don't
give a [ __ ] you've been doing that i've
been through that so now i can't have
homegirls and i don't even think about
it like that you get me
but you're not there
so a lot of guys have to stop lying to
themselves okay they're not messing up
your head
now the one identity that i would say is
like some women
will sometimes keep dudes that they know
are into them as friends and they're
dishonest about it so some women do that
but
you have to acknowledge your part in
this because that's the only thing that
you can control and you have 100 percent
control of that situation so i just want
to say that definitely
if you're wondering how the spotlight is
going i i do the um 150 minutes so i
show up in front of people
for a long time after a while it kind of
just came to the realization that
i'm just not anybody's type which is
okay you know
oh it used to it used to bother me and
like have me like down but
at some point it becomes normal like the
status quo and then you find yourself
inside of your room maybe my bio is too
like goofy you know i'm saying i say
that i'm a goofball i'm from the south
uh proud of my southern roots um i would
love to have adventures with people it
might be my swipe right if you guys
because i truly believe that
communication is the number one
responsibility of both people inside of
the relationship you should be able to
talk to each other about anything
without being vulnerable or feeling as
if the other person is going to judge
you because nobody wants that in a
relationship but if you're out there and
you have never had anybody match with
you or anybody interested in you or
never really felt love and affection or
physical touch from another person do
what i do and just get a bunch of like
plushies and giant pillows it
it works wonders like i'm i got a lot of
things to cuddle with so i'm i'm okay
you know
[Laughter]
i'm not hurt by that comment
okay all right jokes inside jokes
joker's like
uh yeah i think he's a cool dude
he's a cool dude you have a lot of
potential but the the the social media
is not necessarily going to highlight
that thing social media and social
dating is really good for
average girl it boosts your ego and i'm
not saying it's not hard for average
girl
i'm an average girl and it's not good
for you then that means you're ugly uh
but um
other than that
it's just that that type
is not good for you it's not that you're
not nobody's type is
the dating app is not your thing
that's really that
that's really that you got comedy uh
timing and stuff like that start a new
comedy start start dancing classes take
language classes go out there and prove
yourself and stuff like that but the
dating classes that's not that's not
true
go on improv tonight go ahead you say
he's really cool right but i think i
think he's cool yeah we see that because
we're seeing him through this lens a lot
of times you could have somebody you
think is cool in your life then you see
them with the opposite sex and they
start acting goofy or funny they start
acting outside of themselves
some of you just need to get used to
just talking to the opposite sex and
recognizing that they're human beings
and people and not this like desperate
thing that can like make you happy all
right some y'all come up and you the way
you talk to like he's like bro i saw you
five minutes ago you were normal now
you're just stumbling all over your
words and you're like you're saying
things that even you think is absolutely
cringe
maybe you just need to start to get used
to just talking to the opposite sex
without wanting anything don't get their
number don't ask them out on a date just
have a regular ass conversation with
them right get used to just doing that
any girls any just be comfortable around
them and also you know you're reading
off your profile trying to figure out
this stuff another thing that i also
think a lot of people are not honest
about okay
is that they say i don't get no matches
no you don't get no matches that are up
to your standards
maybe the standards that you have are
too high
that's not just ladies there's dudes out
there who don't understand what their
market value is based off the picture or
profile that they got okay you guys are
a four or five on tinder okay expecting
to get the seven eights in real life you
might be a six or seven i don't know but
on tinder your pictures aren't that
great you don't translate well
your standards are too high for that
platform you gotta recognize that
because i promise you if i took over
your profile for half a day i'd get some
matches you might not like the way they
look you might not want to get with them
but you would get matches which means
it's not that you're completely
undesirable you're not just not
desirable to the people that you want
based off however you set your [ __ ] up
maybe it's time to lower your standards
that's also a possibility i can't say
because i don't know you personally but
this is just general advice for a lot of
people out there because like the two
guys we saw they weren't ugly
i know ugly people they were just
average maybe slightly below average
there's ugly [ __ ] out there i
know them that's not you i'm when we
talk about
busted quasimodo [ __ ]
you not quasimodo you're that's not you
right so you also have to be honest
about why you're failing and where
that's coming from right so i mean i
mean i mean i mean
what
i could use a little bit of skincare
product on your face i don't know let's
gently you know what i mean something
we're not doing it
i know it's a struggle i know it's hard
it is because when all you know is
rejection it's like impossible to
imagine you on the other side but like
i've seen a lot of my friends go through
like i've seen myself go through you can
get on the other side it is absolutely
possible so just be patient with
yourself and understand like it's going
to take some work because unfortunately
you don't have what it takes to make it
easy for you so you're going to have to
do a little extra labor but if you're
willing to do that if you're willing to
take up these activities i promise you
can't come on the other side so um
that'd be my advice yeah
yeah
there's a lot of people out there
struggling with this
not everybody's gonna end up with
someone
you better you better work the best that
you can to
you know
if that's what you want yeah
yeah but put the best thoughts in your
on your side yeah
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below we want to hear from you
do you think our advice was bad do you
disagree if we want to hear